it's no secret that in the late 19th
century the great powers didn't get
along yet these nations despite their
mutual distrust and rivalries all work
together to suppress china's boxer
rebellion at the turn of the 20th
century which raises the question why
why did so many great powers work
together despite the fact that they
hated each other so first a brief
overview the boxer rebellion began in
1899 and came about as a result of the
qing government's weakness against
foreign colonial powers these powers had
received major concessions from the
chinese including economic domination in
several provinces ownership of important
ports freedom to proselytise throughout
all of china and europeans were also
exempt from chinese law all of these
were embarrassing for china but the last
two in particular were saw points for
the chinese people it wasn't long until
some of them took matters into their own
hands and began to want themselves and
retaliate against foreigners in china
against the wishes of the chinese
government these rebels who were known
outside of china as boxers because of
their knowledge of martial arts soon
raised an army and laid siege to the
foreign quarter of beijing in response
an international coalition of countries
mostly great powers arrived to put down
the rebellion which they did so why did
so many nations get involved and why did
they put aside their differences to do
so the first reason why all of these
nations got involved was because their
citizens were in immediate danger and
many feared a bloodbath there was a fear
that the europeans and christians in
china were going to be slaughtered and
so for the wider publics of the great
powers as well as the churches in their
countries it was a moral imperative that
these people be saved the second reason
was prestige having your people harmed
wasn't just bad for them but it also
would have hurt the nation's
international standing the third reason
was money although in varying degrees
for each country the united states
wanted china to open up to trade in the
same way that japan had done in the mid
19th century because for america china
was primarily a market for exports
britain france russia and germany wanted
to maintain their monopolies and
privileges in the parts of china that
they had influence over japan's
involvement was also about making it
clear that china was in their backyard
and that they wish to be treated as a
great power equal to the others whereas
austria-hungary's and italy's motives
were much more about chinese calling
stations these two didn't have any
colonies of their own in asia and so to
keep that part of the world open to them
they needed access to the neutral
chinese culling facilities these were
open to any country ships and so unlike
those controlled by another imperial
power there was no risk of them being
closed off italy had another reason and
that was that it didn't have any of the
same privileges in china that the other
european powers had they had tried to
get them earlier but the qing rulers
told them no and so if italy was to be
seen as an established power it needed
to obtain some and so together they all
fought to defeat the boxer rebellion and
you would hope that working together
would create a sense of brotherhood
between the nations involved to decrease
tensions but that's not how early 20th
century great power politics worked and
just over a decade later it was time for
the first world war
i hope you enjoyed this episode with a
special thanks to my patrons james
bissonette kelly moneymaker mr wolfe
skye chappelle adam stalter jordan
longley rod d martin gareth turner wyan
hockey jerry lamdin spencer lightfoot
corso wolff boogerly wiggly marvin
cassar winston k wood gustav swan marcus
asner captain cydog aaron the white
matthew shipley robert wetzel alex
schwinn maggie paxkowski the mcwhopper
anthony beckett coppertone spinning
through plates charles the first ben
evanson scottish trekkie and words about
books podcast